a war that began for the control of
strategic cities has become a nightmare
for tiny Villages far from the front
line Rescuers picked through Rubble for
hours after one of the war's deadliest
attacks a Russian strike on a cafe and
local shop in G roza in rural
kariv dozens dead and several wounded
but no obvious military sites no high
value targets a guided missile used on
MERS attending a funeral for a local
Soldier families left searching for the
missing we came here when we heard the
explosion and then learned what happened
in herza my mother was
here in this community of only a few
hundred people everyone seems to have
lost someone children among the
casualties it was a reburial for a
fighter that was buried somewhere else
before people held a memorial ceremony
people gathered then a missile struck
many people died my mother died my
brother and my
sister-in-law bodies lay strewn around
the blast site people wander the rubble
trying to identify loved
ones investigators say they'll need to
use DNA testing to identify some of the
remains just hours earlier President
Vladimir zelinsky's message to European
leaders at a summit in Spain now seems
eily
preent let only butin Ambitions be
ruined not our countries not our people
not our cities children of every country
deserve to be secure and everywhere in
the country not just in the subway not
just in the shelters underground but
everywhere it is the kind of attack
ukrainians say could have happened
anywhere in the country another example
they say of Russia's indiscriminate
targeting of
civilians Ukraine's top leaders will no
doubt be pointing to this attack as an
example of why they need more modern
weapons and better air defense systems
as soon as possible to bring a quicker
end to this war Zan basravi Al jazer
zapara make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer